[Musique]
salut elle aimait ces gens voyaient un
canapé il me rend sa peau on va la
refaire
vas-y vous le savez lundi le bda revient
avec des images de série voilà et on a
un gros truc dans la rue après avait
bien sûr juste après d'ailleurs hélas je
suis revenu avec des images de ma série
préférée à rennes blanche
j'adore voilà ils sont un sur idf1 sur
idf1 bien sûr ils sont connus grâce à
nous aujourd'hui
d'habitude j'ai tendance un petit peu a
critiqué le jeu des acteurs parce qu'ils
jouent pas forcément super bien là c'est
le contraire l'acteur qui suis-je ou
limitent trop bien c'est à dire qu'il a
rajouté deux trois trucs à sa palette
pour que sa séquence de pleurer lâche
crédible problème sa voix de conteur un
petit peu décrédibilisée toute la
séquence quoi c'est parti mais fais ce
que je ne veux plus entendre parler de
cette femme dans les assemblées
est ce que c'est votre film c'est vrai
que la dame il en a mis un point là on
était juste au dessus c'est un point
très visiblement le délire là bas c'est
de prendre de l'hélium avant de pleurer
bah ça fonctionne ensuite su résister
sur la reine blanche achats d'or sauf
que là je vous dit j'adore à l'agent sur
l'épisode 124 qui fait qu'au bout de 124
épisode c'est un petit peu compliqué de
tenir le téléspectateur en haleine
niveau suspense
heureusement les gars du son ont eu une
idée pour que même quand il se passe pas
grand chose
on est quand même l'impression qu'il ait
du suspense écoutez bien les effets
sonores on n'est pas loin de star wars
caroline dis-moi dis-moi quelle ce que
le musée raconte est faux
malheureusement c'est vrai quoi nous
nous sommes mariés avant d'arriver ici
ouah c'est l'heure mais c'est pas truqué
un seydou très bientôt
pascal à bernard montiel qui me
demandait c'était nettement sa part je
crois vraiment que c'est lui qui a
rajouté qu'il met dans sous le soleil il
y restait d'ailleurs sous le soleil il a
dû y rester
ensuite j'ai passé sur les mystères de
l'amour je crois que la séquence qui
suit va vous plaire alors je me
contextualise le parrain de la série a
tenté un homicide qui s'est mal passé à
savoir un truc sur les parent c'est que
d'autres personnages c'est un peu un
parrain de la mafia pieds noirs
par contre dans son accent c'est un
parent du poitou charentes c'est moi
j'ai vu que tu m'avais c'est un message
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on doit avoir
la scoumoune
la voiture a explosé mais jeanne garnier
n'était pas dedans j'ai l'impression
qu'on a la scoumoune a ensuite su rester
sur des mystère d'amour
ah ouais voilà bon alors moi ce que
j'aime bien dans cette série c'est
qu'ils ont des moyens ce qui fait qu'ils
ont un acteur pour jouer à peu près tous
les rôles qu'ils ont une chanteuse un
bad boy un par un mais il n'avait pas de
matelas
ils ont pris une actrice tanda et lui
ont dit voilà joue de la batterie mais
pas trop près de la batterie sinon ça va
se voir que tu sais pas en jouer
[Musique]
pour qu'ils tuent
ça d'ailleurs n'ont pu passer sur demain
nous appartient sur tf1 alors je regarde
rarement mais il se passe des noces via
un mec qui traitera sera demain nous
appartient anna paquin d'ailleurs demain
nous appartient ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les épisodes sont très courts
ça dure 26 minutes près du coup dans un
épisode il doit tout se passait dans la
série les actrices ont pas le temps de
demander à leurs copains d emmener au
ciné ou au resto non faut aller droit au
but je crois que c'est pour ça que ça
sera la prochaine série préférée de
janvier ouais je crois que t'as pas
vraiment compris pourquoi on était là en
fait se rencontrer un peu quoi pour
baiser ça fait des mois qu'on va pas
toucher
ah ouais ah ouais quand même si je ne
fais pas à 19h la balle mais pas toi
dimanche après-midi au spectacle dévalue
bundle haye était beinheim rsno jai vue
pas tensions avec elle c'est vrai ouais
j'avais vu moi mais je vivais moi
c'était plus vieux de la salle après ça
je serai dans la rue j'adore voilà alors
comme vous savez ce week-end une vague
de froid qui s'est abattue sur la france
mais bizarrement il ya deux semaines à
biarritz les gens pouvaient se baigner
encore il est 32e excès ou fait a eu
alors là il ya eu ou non mais c'est
chaud froid alors justement fait
attention de la série et là franchement
dans couvrez vous bien et bien sûr on
pense à toutes les personnes sans abri
et on va essayer de les aider aussi
encore cette année et bien sûr on va
aider encore les restos du coeur parce
que là ça va commencer à être difficile
on rentre dans une période dure et là il
paraît qu'il va faire de plus en plus
froid mon chéri donc toi tu as été dans
la rue je suis allé dans la rue où je
devais aller à biarritz chercher des
images malheureusement la prod m'a pas
payé mon billet doux ou bas je suis allé
dans la rue à paris où j'ai tout quand
j'ai fait j'aurais fait directement
barré sur le chèque du coup j'ai été
demandé aux parisiens ont vu que j'étais
un peu en galère de m'aider et de me
faire croire qu'ils étaient à biarritz
et vous allez voir ils ont accepté c'est
parti tu travailles non pas du tout
autant perdre je vais peut-être avoir
besoin de toi je t'explique et je devais
être à biarritz ce week-end pour tourner
des images de gens à la plage quand même
c'est que j'ai pas pu ériger plus besoin
de quelqu'un qui accepte de dire qu'être
pas ça sera en plan très serré sur ta
tête on verra pas du tout est rangé ses
bons et ya juste une question
c'est juste une question alors je suis
avec marie on se trouve ou maillot jaune
et à biarritz où ça exactement sur la
plage très bien quel temps il fait bien
il fait très beau très chaud 30 degrés
oui qu'est-ce que tu conseillerais aux
gens pour qu'ils tirent un peu sur la
plage une petite glace ferait pas de mal
âgé de 20 ans surtout est ce que tu
pourrais me sauvé la vie parce que si je
ramène pas les images fraîchement la
mère est là on peut acheter
car attention voilà ce que tu conseilles
de mettre un peu d'eau axée sur la
planche ouais ouais
l'awacs oui oui c'est parfait alors je
suis avec loïc lui qui joue pas bien de
tous
bah oui j'aurais dû apprendre à mieux
protéger ouais on fait un petit trou
parce que la pâte et alors je suis
toujours à biarritz avec loïc je crois
qu'il ya plein de petits coups de soleil
lui tout à fait ils redoutent protéger
je me suis fait avoir encore une fois
quoi franchement mettez-vous à l'ombre
et prenait de quoi ou vous équiper parce
que ça chauffe ça vaut le coup et pour
finir en profiter ça va pas durer
longtemps
merci beaucoup des composants pays c'est
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]